back here at home increasing awareness  about sex trafficking that was the goal  of a be  a shiro foundation event today the  organization hosted its annual awareness  gala to support victims of sex  trafficking  the funds raised help provide shelter  and promote education and support  to abused and exploited victims of sex  trafficking  the organization's founder talked to us  about the importance of raising  awareness  we helped bring the normalcy the dreams  and the hopes back into their lives  to get them out of this dark space to  have the courage  to connect and speak in front of the  courts of law  miles said her organization works to  provide the resources needed to support  sustain and empower young girls and  women who've been abused neglected  and exploited the charity also works in  collaboration with other agencies